i am so excited to be working with this
company to shine a light on them
and their female ceo
because at the age of 27 a family
tragedy
thrust her into the spotlight when she
became the youngest
female ceo of a publicly traded
company firm at the time take a look
lifeways stands for something it stands
for survival
resilience and taking care of yourself
your family and your community
lightweight kefir is like a probiotic
cultured
yogurt like it's like a smoothie maybe
would be the best way to describe it
it's got like a tangy effervescent uh
texture and flavor to it kefir
originated in the caucus mountains where
the people who lived there lived past
100 years of age
and they attributed their longevity to
their consumption
of kefir my ancestors basically passed
it on generation to generation
when my parents started lifeway over 30
years ago
there was no kefir in the united states
and they really
launched an entire new category here
that's with a 2 000 year old product we
were
one of 40 uh 42 families that were
allowed to settle in chicago
in 1976 he did be defected in the middle
of the night from the soviet union
you you can only take one suitcase with
you
with a hundred and fifteen dollars in
our pocket you know my parents didn't
speak a word of english and started this
business
my dad really wanted me to come work in
the family business i spent
five years working with him side by side
he really empowered me
unfortunately when i was 27 he was 55 he
had a sudden heart attack and passed
away and it was
devastating it was absolutely one of the
most challenging things that i
had had to go through ultimately
i became the youngest female ceo of a
publicly traded company
we grew from 12 million to over 100
million today
we went from 70 employees to over 300
today
and i hope that there's uh you know kids
watching me young people people who have
a dream for
an idea a business plan whatever
whatever your dream is to go
forward just go do it and don't stop
fantastic words of wisdom
please welcome the ceo of lifeway foods
julie smalenski
thank you i have to just have a sip
right now
so my mom raised me in california in the
70s
and 80s and she was a key for fanatic
i marveled at the chance of talking to
you
and then i just felt like wow we have a
lot in common with two daughters
and going to work so young when i was
reading about your life like you really
had to hit the ground
running at a very young age yeah well
you know i mean nobody believed in me
my father's friend said to me you know
five feet away from me on the day that
my dad died
there's no way a 27 year old girl could
run a company
that's it it's over sell your stock and
you know truly nobody believed in me
they said it to my face
and you learn how to stick up for
yourself you learn how to advocate for
yourself
but more importantly i learned how to
trust my gut
and have confidence in my gut and that
intuition that we all
have that i think women especially have
this untapped intuition that you know we
know how to lead in crisis and we know
what to do and that you know following
and taking care of your gut to me has
become
you know my purpose and helping people
make those healthy choices i mean this
is what my ancestors have done for 2000
years and
now science is catching up to to that
intuitive knowledge that we have
you were so ahead of the game you and
your family with gut health
by the way i'm sorry try to find
something that's good for you that
tastes as good as kiefer
yes i literally it's since childhood
been my absolute favorite thing
um i really love the way
that you speak to your daughters i was
fortunate enough to write a book and
the reason i wrote that book was a love
letter to my daughter so that they could
understand
who i was and how i grew up and
really the two things that were most
important that i wrote in the book were
my little letters to them
dear olive and dear frankie and when i
read your instagram
to your daughters i was bold over what
compelled you to write those
captions to your daughters well i
recognize that one day i'm not going to
be here
and all they'll have are those words my
words that are
you know a piece of my soul that will
give them glimmers of who their mom was
and what she overcame but i think that's
the really incredible thing about women
and girls is we have these
untold stories that are just burning
inside of us to get out to share with
the world
and you know little kids are watching
boys and girls need to hear
these stories stories like yours stories
like mine
that can inspire them to recognize that
no matter what challenge is in front
of them no matter what card they are
dealt with they can thrive
they cannot just survive but thrive i
think
as a daughter your father
must be so proud i thank you julie
likewise thank you so much i'm just
gonna give a quick shout out to the
seventh graders at near north montessori
my daughter's friends all
helped me get my outfit together
everyone voted
good job near north montessori kids and
yeah
my daughters leanne misha we did a whole
fashion show
so we we got the whole uh whole crew
involved in the fashion
well julie smolansky thank you so much
and lifeway and kiefer do yourself a
favor
and take good care of yourself by
drinking this thank you julie thank you
so much